this is a nice cheers to uh back-to-back
albums of the year now I don't know if
Kendricks like so by I don't know if
Kendricks gonna drop this year and put
out his illmatic I don't know but we are
in June of 2020 and you have the album
of the year that's my only competition
I'll be looking at it like kyndra's I'd
be like uh sort of last like seven
interviews all my bad he asked me like
who wrapped but I think was always want
to add rappers about rappers I [ __ ]
like who's the guy who kind of like I
wouldn't say the word scares you but
like who's the guy who you're like gonna
scare me but I look at him and I'll be
like yeah he's sharp you know I mean I
want to be sharp like that you know I
mean he wanted all these [ __ ] that I
look at like that him and like I said
like black top I'd be like damn oh damn
they don't like doing songs with black
yeah I've actually once that black cloth
wash you on a record
exactly that's why I had to get him on a
[ __ ] bed down a shadow of a
doubt that's why I had to get on bandana
and then you got him back him back to
reek so whatever you want your rematch
you get in it but the respect you're the
best you're the best oh you're the best
but whatever you want to remand the
respect for Kendrick like talk about
that because I feel like I feel the same
way Kendrick obviously is one of the
most commercially successful chorus but
he's also like just one of the best
technical rappers ever of all time so
when you when you like Kendrick is one
of those guys who you cuz you're one of
those guys - there's a few of you guys
there's push the tee there's a few of
those guys not a lot there's not a lot
dude it's like four or five y'all it
ain't that many Jedi's or disruption
there's a lot of you [ __ ] can't pull
out their laser sword Kendrick is kind
of the guy who you're like okay got like
Kendrick I look at Kendrick push I'll be
like what and then they push this hot
judge a rapper yeah I [ __ ] you know
if I buy into your character first of
all I gotta buy into your character
you know if I look at your character and
I think your character is flaw and
[ __ ] I mean I don't [ __ ] that no I'm
saying being I look at the N I look at
your technical skill right you know I
mean your technical skill you know you
know that means a lot so I look at guys
like Kendrick and pushing even Drake man
Drake is one of the best I mean I mean I
don't got to say his name
because the chart the chart speak for
itself but but I don't decide from the
like the chart [ __ ] I think a wrap
great you know I'm saying so you know
and I feel like you can't be great in
this [ __ ] unless like you like no you
got to study the game I look at [ __ ]
every time I look at everybody you know
matter like what what kind of genre rap
it is you know how you rapping I look at
my study and I'll be like man you know I
mean damn like I gotta stay relevant
listen you're a basketball game a
basketball guy if you had to assemble
your fantasy basketball starting five
line above emcees yes I mean Kendrick at
the point I'm putting you with the two
ladies on my rapping rapping okay that's
okay we got Kendrick at the point
running point I got you at the - yes I'm
it's a two year at the - either the two
to three I'm like Jimmy Butler I'm gonna
do okay you go either way you could lock
up somebody yeah I need to know who's
filling out that small forward power
forward and center on the squad best
rappers in the game best rappers in the
game right now right I'll be going like
no I'm talking about right now right now
like five to five of the five best
rappers in the game right now
Kendrick push Cray gives you your one
yeah so we got we got three more names
you gotta fill out so we got push push
is one of them this is one mile hike so
pushes is a staple Drake we tell my
[ __ ] with just [ __ ] with bars listen
man I'm just waiting for Drake to drop a
classic album and I think he might have
one and take care but I I agree with
something on [ __ ] with bars right rank
is on that level I just I just barf a
bar he's there he's there oh we guys we
got we got one more mm-hmm damn that's
crazy think about I'm thinking about bar
i'ma let you do two more we'll get both
other six man in there oh we thought we
could go to six man and then
[ __ ] okay if we go you know me
and go one more [ __ ] with bars man bro
you somewhere right now right now right
now okay Lee Tarik Black Dog
that [ __ ] get bars bro off the bench
I'm taking rosa butcher Benny the
butcher or killer Mike yeah that's the
right there